صباح العربيه فهد الشهري فهد يسعد صباحك
خروج مشرف للسعوديه من المونديال بعد اداء
مميز في حديثنا اكثر كيف كانت اجواء
المباراه
جميله بالامس صراحه يعني من حضور الجمهور
توافد الجمهور لشراء التذاكر او بالامس
اول مره موقع الفيفا اللي يبيع التذاكر
يعيد بيع التذاكر لاكثر من مره نظرا
لاقبال الشديد طبعا هي الاليه انه الفيفا
بيقدر يحصي من همم اشترى التذكره ولم يدخل
اراضي الدوحه فعاد اكثر من مره نظرا
لاقبال على الموقع كان اقبال شديد للامانه
شهادتنا الالاف خارج الملعب امس ينتظرون
تذاكر انتظروا موازنه الاخضر الاخضر نعم
غادر ولكنه ترك اسمه ترك العلامه الابرز
العلامه الابرز كانت هنا في الدوحه هو
الجمهور السعودي الجمهور السعودي كان تجده
في كل مكان يحتفل يشجع
ويضع الثقه في لعيبه المنتخب السعودي
ويحتفلون ايضا
الصدر عده همم رسائل عده اهازيج وصلت كل
العالم ايضا جمهور المنتخب السعودي كان
اول جمهور يعمل تيفو في المدرج في تاريخ
كاس العالم بالكامل نعم حتى وان غادر
المنتخب السعودي المجموعات من الدور الاول
ولكن لا زال اسمه
يجون بين الرياضيين هنا لازال اسمه موجود
والمنتخب الذي هزم المنتخب الارجنتيني
المرشح الاول للبطوله
وفهد ان شاء الله كمان يعني في الايام
المقبله نشوف ابتسامتك على الهواء كمان
اكثر واكثر هيك على الصبح ايوه هيك طيب
فهد اليوم
المعلومات
السعوديين من اكثر الشعوب العربيه
والتواجدا في قطر في مونديال 20 22 ما هي
الخطط السعوديه ما بعد خروج من المونديال
يعني بالنسبه للتواجد السعودي في قطر
نعم لا زالت تواجد السعودي موجود فانا
نظام النظر الى نظرا لقرب المسافه يعني
نشجع السعوديه ليس كلهم سيعود رغم انه
يعني رغم ان انا لا حطنه بعض السعوديين
حظر وهذا شيء يشكر عليه حظر من الحدود او
من المطار الى الملعب وعاد مره اخرى
للمطار
للدوامات اليوم هذا موقف ايجابي موقف
بطولي يحسب للمشجع السعودي ولكن المشجع
السعودي الاذان موجود ايضا وسائل الاعلام
لازال حتى نهايه كاس العالم ايضا البيت
السعودي البيت السعودي اللي يضم 12 قسم
حكومي راح ينشر الثقافه في السعوديه وهو
متواجد هنا في الدوحه وعليه اقبال كثيف
ويقع في موقع ممتاز في 12 22 فعاليه يوميا
ثقافيه ومتجر لبيع الادوات السعوديه ومتجر
لبيع القمصان السعوديه وايضا فعاليات
ثقافيه وموسيقيه وعرض مسرح متواجد طول
البطوله
الاسم السعودي موجود الجماهير السعوديه
راح تكون موجوده حتى نهايه همم كاس العالم
العديد من الجماهير السعوديه اذا راح
يستمر اليوم وراح يعني يتابعوا المنتخب
المغربي اللي نتمنى ان شاء الله لو
التوفيق وانزفوا ان شاء الله
كاول منتخب عربي ان شاء الله يصل لدور 16
ونحتفل جميع ان شاء الله بوصول المنتخب
المغربي هناك جماهير السعوديه كثير بقت في
الدوحه من اجل حضور مباراه المنتخب
المغربي وكندا اليوم في السادس من مساء
الدوحه شكرا جزيلا من الدوحه مراسل صباح
العربيه فهد الشهري